creep the dude at the grocery store who
coincidentally needs the exact same
ingredients as you and what TLC advise
you should do if your man is cheating
mission creep is the expansion of a
mission beyond its original goals think
Walter White's little science project
mostly it's a military term and this
week it's been thrown around we're
entering the mission preface there is no
mission creep the Pentagon denies it is
mission creep as many are worried that
Obama green-lighting strikes on Isis in
Syria and Iraq will lead to a prolonged
engagement of course the phrase was
strangely absent when it came to double
use what's the strategy this week
strategy in Iraq a strategy that after
nine years a trillion dollars five
thousand US troops and a hundred
thousand Iraqi lives and a 2011
withdrawal Obama now seems to be
continuing mission creep was first used
when Papa Bush sent troops to Somalia to
keep peace during a civil war and then
started training Somali police forces
building homes and even reading
Mogadishu an action that led to the
downing of two blackhawk helicopters
oops
it could also describe the Korean War
when the u.s. achieved the objective of
kicking northern forces out of the south
and then had the brilliant idea to try
and reunite the country which cost more
than 35,000 American lives and resulting
in Oh a still divided Korea or Vietnam
where Lyndon Johnson said the u.s.
sought quote no wider war ten years
two more countries bombs 60,000 troops
and about two million Vietnamese lives
later it's clear there was nothing
contained about containment must the
list go on and maybe the best way to
avoid mission creep is to avoid being
mission sheep want more download the aj+
mobile app and join the conversation
available in your App Store now